[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARKKU LEPISTO: Good
to see all of you.
Rise and shine.
Early morning here.
Hope you found some coffee.
My name is Markku.
I am a solutions
architect at Google Cloud,
and I focus on IoT.
And that's exactly what I would
like to show you this morning.
I'd like to show you how to
build IoT solutions using
Sigfox, Radio Network for IoT
devices, and Google Cloud.
So let's get started.
First I'd like to talk
to you about LPWAN.
What is LPWAN 1, I hear you say.
Well, it's low-power
wide-area networks.
With IoT, it's super important.
OK, you might have an
IoT device in your home,
but many, many IoT devices
are actually out there.
They may be measuring
air quality in a field
or up in a mountain
somewhere, maybe
measuring some flood gates,
water levels in a canal
or whatever.
So they are somewhere.
You may have thousands of them.
We have customers who have
millions of IoT devices,
so there is quite
a bit of scale.
So you want your devices
to be kind of autonomous,
and self managing,
and low maintenance.
You don't want to have
to go there all the time
to charge them and check them.
They need to just
survive on their own.
So low power means that you can
run your devices with battery
power, so you can easily,
with these solutions
that I'll show you
today, build solutions
where the device can run from
a single battery for months
or even years.
And wide area network means
that if your device is up
in a mountain or in a field,
it can still connect--
where?-- to the internet.
So one way to do that is with
our technology partner, Sigfox.
So Sigfox is providing a radio
network specifically for IoT.
They call it 0G, not 4G, 5G.
They go the other way, 0G.
It's extremely low bandwidth,
but it's really, really nice
for IoT.
I'll show you.
And when you build
IoT solutions,
you, unfortunately, also
need to consider the cost.
So there's a lot
of cost elements.
There's the hardware cost.
So if you buy or specify a
very simple, very constrained
microcontroller, you can
squeeze the hardware cost down.
That's good.
Microcontrollers are also
reliable because they
don't really have
an operating system.
They just get some
power, and they
execute a binary that does
stuff like read the air quality
sensor reading and send it out.
So that's it.
That's the hardware cost.
With Sigfox, you need
a radio module that
would be a couple of dollars.
And then the connectivity
is something like this,
from $15 per device per
year, down to just $1
per device per
year, so that's nice
if you have thousands
or millions of devices.
So Sigfox provide
the radio network,
they build the base
stations, they connect them.
So they provide the coverage.
They currently have about
60 countries covered,
and 21 of those countries
have nationwide coverage.
Now what is a LPWAN1 here?
First of all, with Sigfox
and LPWAN1 networks,
the payload is extremely small.
That's why it's 0G.
It's not 5G.
The maximum data, or
same as the telemetry
usually that you can
send with Sigfox devices,
is 12 bytes uplink-- so from
device up 12 bytes, so 96 bits.
You have 96 bits to play with.
And now you're like,
this cannot be.
It's 2019.
What are you talking about?
12 bytes?
Crazy.
It's good.
You can squeeze a lot of
information in those 12 bytes.
Zero bytes can be
actionable information.
If you just send a
message with no payload,
it's still a message.
It has metadata.
That can be a heartbeat.
I'm still here.
The air quality monitor--
1 bit can transmit 0 or 1.
True or false?
Like, how is the water level
in this drainage canal?
Is it too low, or
is it too high?
No.
Zero.
With six bytes, you can transmit
GPS coordinates, and you still
have six bytes left for
things like sensor readings--
multiple sensor readings.
So that's uplink--
12 bytes up.
And you can transmit about
six messages per hour
with Sigfox network, so that's
about 140 messages per day.
But usually the sensor
readings are sent, like,
every hour, et cetera.
Downlink is then from the
network to the device.
So that could be a command
that you send to the device
to do something, maybe
based on an analytics,
or maybe you want to update
the device configuration.
Now with Sigfox, you cannot
push messages to the devices.
They are not listening
because they are sleeping,
so that they can conserve power.
The radio is off.
So how does it work?
With Sigfox, the
device can set a flag,
so you, in your
code on the device,
can set a flag that says, I want
to have a downlink response.
So when it's sending
something, there's a flag,
and then the network
can send back a downlink
message which is 8 bytes.
So that would be a device
configuration and maybe
some commands.
Now in order for
these devices to have
highly successful
transmission of data,
Sigfox is using narrowband.
It's extremely
narrowband transmission,
192 kilohertz, radio burst.
No protocol.
There is no protocol.
So in order to save power on the
devices, there is no handshake.
There is no connection to
the network and handshake.
Hi, I'm here.
Hello.
No, they just send.
They literally trust
encode the data,
and modulate it with radio,
and send a radio burst.
They actually send, or
transmit, three radio
bursts-- the same
message three times.
They do channel hopping.
They send the same
message three times
consecutively in three
different channels.
This is increasing the
likelihood of the network
hearing and receiving
the message.
And then the rest of
the time, the device
should be sleeping,
especially if it's
battery or maybe solar
powered, so 99 point something
percent of the time, your
device can be in deep sleep.
So nowadays, there's a lot
of microcontrollers, MCUs,
that you can literally
put to a deep sleep mode.
Now if there's a
Sigfox radio there,
while the device is
transmitting it's
consuming some
milliwatts of power.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Thank you
for joining this session.
MARKKU LEPISTO: You're welcome.
And then when the device
has finished transmitting,
you should put it to deep
sleep, and then maybe it
sleeps 10 minutes.
Maybe it sleeps an hour.
Maybe it sleeps a day.
When the MCU, depending on the
microcontroller, is sleeping,
you can go down to
nanowatts-- sorry, nanoamps.
Nanoamps of current.
So the device can actually
consume less power
than the battery's
natural self drainage.
Batteries lose some
power over time,
so you need to choose
some battery types that
keep the power longer without
any loss of power over time.
Anyway, most of the time
the devices are sleeping.
And then the wide area
network part of this
is the link budget.
With radio connections,
radio connectivity--
the link budget means like
if you transmit the signal
from your device, how easily
can the network actually hear
this signal?
And Sigfox is
really good at that.
Depending on the different
countries and frequencies,
if you look at the uplink FCCs--
so that's here in the US--
the devices can
transmit at 22 decibels.
That's a radio power.
And the network
sensitivity for receiving
is minus 134 decibels, so
actually the Sigfox radio
network can hear the
message 134 decibels lower
than the transmission power--
so very, very weak signal.
So in practice, it means that if
a Sigfox device is transmitting
in urban areas where there's
buildings and stuff like that,
you have a few miles of a
distance to the base stations,
but in rural areas, maybe
some fields, et cetera,
you can have dozens of miles,
dozens of kilometers' range.
So that's good.
So let's get to the
integration now.
So Sigfox is one option for
you to have connectivity,
especially for remote
devices, somewhere,
and Google Cloud can
then help with the data.
So the main point is this.
Your devices emit the essential
readings-- maybe air quality,
whatever--
Sigfox antennas pick
up these messages,
the Sigfox platform
can optionally then
forward the data--
forward the messages
to a backend system.
And in this case, we can use
Google Cloud and our data
services in GCP to
receive, analyze, store,
and have actionable
insights from the data--
maybe even machine learning.
So to help with
this, in January,
we published the integration.
The QR code there and
the URL on the top
bring you to that tutorial,
so it's fully open source.
The tutorial gives you
the step-by-step guide
on how to actually
integrate your Sigfox
account and your
Google Cloud account,
and everything is open source,
and all the code is in GitHub.
It works like this.
On your left, you have
the Sigfox devices.
When they transmit messages
with your sensor readings,
they call the Sigfox
system, Sigfox platform.
And then you can configure
a so-called callback
or multiple callbacks
that, if you will get data
from your devices, or if
there's something else to notify
the backend system, Sigfox
can push the messages
to a backend system.
And that's what we
have implemented
with the integration
in Google Cloud,
and we are using Cloud
Functions for that.
Because with Sigfox, first of
all, you have very small data--
maximum 12 bytes per device--
and at maximum, a single device
can transmit every 10 minutes.
So most of the time,
there's very little traffic
unless you have
millions of devices,
so Cloud Functions are
really handy because you
can scale them down.
They appear.
Your compute system appears
when there's a message,
so the payload will
trigger the compute.
So it's event-driven computing.
And its serverless,
meaning that you
don't have any servers
running, and you
don't need to manage any
servers or even any containers.
So the Cloud Function will
receive the data from Sigfox.
There is, of course,
authentication and encryption
for the link there.
Then the Cloud
Function will check
that the message looks OK.
It's conforming to
the Sigfox standards.
So what is coming to
the Cloud Function
is the payload from your device
and then metadata around that,
like what is the device?
What is the device type?
Maybe what is the Sigfox
operator, like US, et cetera?
So there's the metadata
and then the payload.
And remember the payload is
binary encoded, maximum 12
bytes.
Once the Cloud Function receives
this payload and metadata,
it will drop them
in Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub is our
global message queue
so it's a really
handy place for you
to keep your data
reliably up to seven days
and then process the data
from this message queue
with your data
processing system.
So in effect, you get a
real-time streaming data, off
payload, into Cloud Pub/Sub.
And if the devices are
requesting a configuration
update, a downlink message,
then the Cloud Function
will detect this flag
that the device is saying,
hey, I want to have
a downlink message.
And we use Cloud Datastore as
a really simple, easy, handy
database service to store
the device configurations.
So you will create the
device configurations.
We check the device
ID, device type ID.
If they are requesting a
downlink, we get the payload--
the configuration
from Datastore--
and the Cloud Function
sends it back to the device
through the Sigfox network.
Also, if the Sigfox network is
sending any service messages,
we have a second Cloud
Function receiving those--
and just logging
everything in Stackdriver,
which is the logging
system in Google Cloud.
Now that is the integration,
and the integration
is device independent.
It's solution independent.
It works with any
solution with Sigfox
because it just takes the
payload as is and drops it
in Pub/Sub, but
every IoT solution
will be different, based on
your devices and use cases.
So after Pub/Sub, it's good to
have a device specific and use
case specific backend system.
For example, you can use
another Cloud Function.
Then you look at this payload
in Pub/Sub or Dataflow.
With Cloud Dataflow,
you can create
Apache Beam DACs,
Directed Acyclic Graphs,
of data processing steps.
You can enrich data, you
can branch it, whatever.
So Dataflow is great for that.
And after
preprocessing the data,
you want to store the
data in a data store.
We have many handy services
for that, like Cloud Bigtable.
It's extremely
fast and scalable.
Key value store-- very
good for time series data,
and a lot of IoT
data is time series.
But BigQuery definitely is
probably the most likely data
store that many people use.
It's becoming a data
lake, if you will.
So with BigQuery, you can store
your data there in real time,
so the system can write the
data in BigQuery in real time.
Then your data warehouse
is up to date in real time.
You can run machine learning
inside BigQuery on your data
without moving it
anywhere, and of course you
can have analytics,
dashboards, et cetera
connected to your
BigQuery data warehouse.
And you can use Cloud,
ML, and other machine
learning services then
to do things, like, maybe
predictive maintenance, looking
at trending of your sensor
values.
I talked through the functional
requirements on the left
already, but when I
created this integration,
we set some non-functional
requirements as well.
So we wanted this
to be serverless--
so we don't have to worry about
running servers or managing
them--
event driven, and stateless,
and scale out, of course,
if there a lot of traffic,
but importantly also scale
in even to zero.
So if there's no messages
coming from your Sigfox devices,
the system will scale in
and kind of hibernate,
and it's woken by the
messages, and that
means-- that's what
event-driven architecture means.
The messages will
wake up the system,
and it will process
your messages.
And of course, everything is
customizable and open source.
Now with that, let's
actually see the demo.
So live demos-- so first, we
switch to my Sigfox backend.
So when you create
a Sigfox account,
you'll get access to
the backend system,
and then for your devices,
or device types which
are groups of devices,
you can optionally
configure these callbacks.
So these callbacks
are the instructions
in the Sigfox network side.
If your devices are
sending data, do something.
Send it somewhere else
to a backend system.
So we can see here that,
in my Sigfox backend,
we have some callbacks
already configured.
And if you can see over
there, the callbacks
are actually implemented
by cloudfunctions.net, so
Google Cloud Functions.
We have different
callbacks here for data,
for service messages, et cetera.
Now as part of the
integration, of course,
you can use the user interface,
but I also made a command line
tool that uses the Sigfox API.
Because to configure
the callbacks,
it can be a bit
tedious if there's
a lot of parameters, et cetera.
So we are humans.
We make human
mistakes, human errors.
So I wanted to automate it.
And also, then maybe you
can build a CI/CD pipeline
that uses these
command line tools
as part of your automation.
So to use the Sigfox
API command line
tool that's part of the
integration in GitHub,
first, we can execute
callbacks list.
And there is a
configuration file,
which then has your credentials
and your API keys and points
to your system in Sigfox.
On the bottom, you
can see that now,
for this Sigfox device type
which is the one for the demos,
we have five
callbacks configured.
That's right.
We have five of them here.
But if we use,
now, the same API,
and we execute callbacks
delete all, oh, dear.
Gone.
So now the API client said we
deleted the five callbacks.
If we refresh the
screen, they're gone.
That's it.
And let's put them back.
So simply, I just execute
create, if I can type it.
There is a configuration file.
There's a JSON file which
contains the callback
configuration.
So mine are examples, and if you
need to modify them or add them
you can simply modify this
JSON config file and add
or modify more callbacks.
So this script will read that
JSON file, and by default it
will create these five callbacks
that point to Google Cloud
Functions.
There we go.
Now it's back.
So let's actually now
go back to the slides
and start using this system.
Let me show you, really
quickly, a piece of the code.
So this is the Sigfox
API command line
tool that we just used.
Sigfox has a Swagger
configuration
file for the API,
API version 2, and we
generated a Python client.
In this case, it's in Python.
And how it works is very simple.
I've got the JSON file that
contains the configuration,
the desired configuration,
for the Sigfox callbacks that
point to Cloud
Functions in this case,
and then the script will
just run through all
of those in the template.
In this case, it does five loops
and calls the API instance,
create callback function,
for each of those callback
configuration.
So very simply-- to loop
through and automatically create
the integration.
So that's handy.
Now let's actually use it, so
let's have a live demo now.
I've got here, on stage, my
Sens'it Discovery version 3
device.
It's a microcontroller
that's battery powered.
I charge it every couple
of months, if I remember,
so the battery
lasts a long time.
It's an off-the-shelf
development kit
that's handy for getting
started with Sigfox,
and IoT, and Google Cloud.
It's got a lot of
sensors, ambient sensors--
temperature, humidity.
There's a magnetic senator.
There's an accelerometer,
light sensor,
et cetera, and of
course a Sigfox radio.
So let's now see
what we have here.
So we have the integration,
which is the middle gray part.
You saw that or part of that.
And on the right side, we have
a device specific backend,
so when this device is sending
data it has a defined payload.
It's got the sensors,
and depending
on the mode of the device it
actually changes the payload.
So the payload is
dynamic, but as
part of the payload the device
is transmitting a value--
what is my mode?
Mode one is temperature
and humidity.
So then the rest of the
payload, actually, we
know that it contains
temperature and humidity
information, so that's a
device specific payload that
leverages those 12
bytes-- actually
only four bytes in this case.
So to handle the device
specific data, on your right,
I've created a device
specific backend,
and we have also published this
as an open source tutorial.
And let's take a
look at that now.
So let's use this integration
with the Sigfox Sens'it device,
so let me show you the device.
Here it is.
On the table, it's quite small.
So it's a battery powered MCU
with some sensors built in,
small LiPo battery in
there, and a button.
And then let's go back to my
laptop before we send any data.
So remember we've got
the callbacks here,
so if any data comes
from my devices,
these callbacks
will be activated,
and Sigfox will send the
data to Google Cloud,
specifically here.
So now we are in Google Cloud,
and this is the receiving side
of the data.
This is the integration in GCP.
We've got the two
callbacks here--
call back data which is
receiving the data payloads,
and the optional
callback service
which is receiving
service messages
and logging those
in Stackdriver.
And we have the logs here.
So this is the callback
data, Stackdriver Logging.
And the device itself is here.
So this is this
particular device,
and now if I switch here, and I
double click this button here,
we should see a blink,
blink, blink here.
There.
It's now transmitting those
three bursts, three radio
bursts.
And we go back here.
You can see green.
Call back OK.
So the Sigfox callback
was activated,
and the arrow turned
green, meaning
that Google Cloud replied with
a positive acknowledgment.
Thank you.
I received the message.
So Sigfox received
the radio transmission
and forwarded the
message to Google Cloud,
and the actual data is here.
You can see that
it's hexadecimal,
signifying that
it's binary encoded.
So eight characters
in hexadecimal
are four bytes, so it's
actually four bytes
of binary encoded data.
I will copy it to my clipboard,
and I can show you later
how to decode it.
So let's go back
now to Google Cloud
look at the callback
data function,
and it should have
been triggered.
Here we go.
So this function was triggered
by the message just now.
And if we go to the
logging of this function,
and we refresh
the logging, here,
we can see in
Stackdriver logging,
it says we received a Sigfox
message from this device type
from this particular
device ID at this time.
The data is there.
You can see the data is still
in hexadecimal binary-encoded
format.
That's the payload.
The operator is here,
and the next message
says that simply we publish
the message to Pub/Sub
to a particular topic, so now
we get the payload in Pub/Sub.
And then your data
processing system
can pick it up from this
message queue in real time--
maybe Cloud Functions
or Dataflow--
and do something with the data.
Now, what did we actually send?
Let me show you.
As part of the integration,
we also published a tutorial
for this particular device--
a tutorial that creates
the device-specific
backend that uses
BigQuery, and we
need to have a parser
because the device is
sending binary payloads.
Those are a little
bit difficult to use,
so let's decode
the binary messages
using the specification
of the device
and then write to BigQuery
a normal set of columns
and values.
So how do we do that?
I have a Cloud Function,
another Cloud function here.
This one, this Cloud Function,
knows the binary payload
of this device type, Sigfox
Sens'it, so that Pub/Sub
BigQuery Cloud Function will
get the messages from Pub/Sub,
which contain a
binary-encoded payload.
It will decode them and
write them to BigQuery.
The same parser also
has a command line tool,
so that you can do
debugging, and testing,
and maybe developing
your own binary payloads.
So it's an example for that.
So here we're going to see
that we could execute Python
Sens'it, which is
this device, parser,
parser mode decoding data for
which hexadecimal string from
my clipboard-- the same
that the device sent.
Then I press Enter,
and now we can
see that the parser
is identifying,
from the mode, what
is the device mode?
There's a certain
two-bit value there
that specifies the device mode.
In this case, it's
temperature and humidity.
And then the rest
of the payload is
decoded using that information,
and we can see it down here,
that the battery level
is now 4.1 volts.
It's 54% humidity, modest
temperature, humidity.
Temperature is 20.2 centigrade,
so it's really chilly here.
And the button
alert flag is true,
meaning that the
device sent the message
because I clicked the button.
The other option is
sending it with a timer.
OK, so now we can
decode the message.
That's what this Cloud
Function does here--
Pub/Sub BigQuery.
If we look at the logging
of this Cloud Function
now, what happens is
that this function
is triggered when the
first function puts
the payload in Cloud Pub/Sub.
So the first function puts
the payload in Pub/Sub as is--
as a hexadecimal binary string.
The second function
is device-specific,
and it knows how to read
this binary payload.
So if we look at the
logging of this function,
we can see here that these
device sent some data.
OK, that's it.
But the next row--
the next row in Stackdriver
logging for this function--
has already opened up the data.
We can see here
that, in addition
to just a binary payload
here, we now have new values.
We have battery level-- we
have temperature and humidity--
so that the next step for
this function can be this.
It formulates a BigQuery row
and then simply writes the data
in streaming mode to BigQuery.
So now the effect is
that, when we send data
from Sigfox devices
using this integration,
your data warehouse, which
can be, for example, BigQuery,
can be real time.
So here we are.
We are in Cloud BigQuery, and
I have a very simple SQL query
here, select star.
I'm not supposed to do that.
Anyway, from this table, ordered
by time descending limit 20--
now let's execute that.
And it's in UK time.
So the last messages
sent by the device
are here, the same data payload,
but you can see in BigQuery
that we have handy
information here-- battery
level, temperature, humidity.
And all the other
sensor readings,
which are not sent
now, but they are
sent in another
mode of the device,
have a place holder here
in the BigQuery schema.
So then, you can start
analyzing in real time
your data warehouse for IoT
data coming from, in this case,
Sigfox devices.
You can have real-time
despots and maybe even
machine learning doing things
like predictive maintenance,
trending, other things
looking at the actual values.
And everything is
end-to-end real time.
Now the device can also send
configuration updates request.
So for example here, you can
see that we have a lot of short
messages-- four bytes--
but every once in
a while the device
is sending a much
longer payload string.
Now what is that?
Let's put this in my clipboard.
I'll copy that to the clipboard.
Go back to the
command line tool,
and let's investigate
what is actually
inside this binary payload.
The parser can now detect that,
actually, this long string
here contains both
the data, which
is the sensor
readings, four bytes,
and an optional configuration.
So when this device is sending
a configuration update request,
it's also sending its
current configuration.
By the way, I'm currently
using these configurations.
And the parser can decode those,
and what you can see here are
the valid configuration
parameters and values
for the Sigfox Sens'it device.
So it's sending all these.
This is the device
configuration,
so this is the device telling
us what it's doing now.
And in order for us to actually
use this and easily update
the configuration, we
can do the following.
We can use the
command line tool,
paste the received payload
from the device here,
and specify that we write
the device configuration
in an output file,
temp/sensit.ini.
Boom.
Config file return
to temp/sensit.ini.
So if we edit this--
it's actually the
current configuration
sent by the device, but
it's in human readable
and human editable format.
So what we could
do, for example,
is change the
message period, which
is the interval of the
device transmitting data.
One, in this device's
case, means every hour.
But if I change the
value from one to zero,
I'm asking the device to
transmit every 10 minutes.
So we modified that
one parameter value--
the first one, message period.
I save it, and then I run the
parser the other way around.
I want to encode a
new configuration
from that configuration
file that we just edited.
Boom.
So all this is open source.
It's in GitHub as part
of the integration,
and even if you
don't use this device
you can use this configuration,
and payload, tools and parsers
as a starting point for you to
develop your own binary-encoded
small sensor readings
and device configs.
So that's the main point here.
So the tool is giving us a
new configuration hexadecimal
string.
That's the desired new
configuration for the device.
Copy it to the
clipboard, and let's now
go to Cloud Datastore.
So Cloud Datastore is where we
keep the device configurations,
and if the device is requesting
new configs we can simply
Modify the value here.
Let's write the new config here.
I click Done, and I click
Save, and that's it.
The next time the
device is saying,
hey, Cloud, can you
give me my new configs,
the Cloud Function
will pick up this value
and send it back to the device.
So that's quite simple.
OK?
Moving on.
So far, what we have seen is we
have seen the Sigfox callback
configuration, we
have seen the device,
we have seen the Cloud Function
that receives the data.
We looked at the logs,
we did some parsing
of the binary payload,
and we saw that the data
lands in BigQuery.
So that's good.
Then you can do your
analytics and data
warehousing in BigQuery.
And how did we actually
do the parsing?
Let's take a quick
look at the code.
I'm using Python's
BitStruct module here,
because it's really
handy that you
can declare a binary payload.
So remember we have up
to 12 bytes of payload--
so 96 bits-- and in order to
use those 96 bits in the most
efficient manner,
you really want
to minimize the number
of bits and bytes
that you use to
convey some data.
So for example, one byte
can be 255 values, right?
It's 2 to the power of whatever.
So 255, that could be, for
example, the speed of your car.
So the speedometer reading
easily fits in one byte.
OK, then you have 11 bytes left.
OK, battery power.
Maybe I can get
by with four bits.
So half a byte.
So you get the idea.
You'll start constructing
the minimum number of bits
that you need to convey
certain values with the desired
accuracy.
You can always drop the accuracy
and get by with less bits
to transmit the data.
So here we have an example from
this device, where first we--
in the top lines there--
we investigate the device mode.
So as part of the
payload from the device,
it sets a certain
value, mode, indicating
what is the current mode, and
then the rest of the payload
is dynamic based on that.
So if the mode value
is 1, then the device
is in temperature humidity mode.
So that's here.
And then as part of
the open source parser,
we have a BitStruct that
specifies exactly how many bits
are used for what values.
And then on the
bottom, we can simply
call this parser to give
us the human readable
values, or standard Python
values like integer,
and float, et cetera
from this binary mess.
Now as the last thing,
what I'd like to show you,
that was the generic
data up and down
with Sigfox and Google Cloud.
A handy thing with Sigfox is
that it can do estimated device
location without any GPS or
GLONASS or other satellite
systems.
Because the Sigfox
network is so-called MIMO,
multiple in, multiple out--
everybody's talking at the same
time--
they have multiple
base stations,
and typically around
three base stations
will receive the same
message from the devices.
So then the Sigfox network
can reverse engineer
and calculate an
estimated position
and location of the device.
It's not as accurate
as GPS of course,
but it's still nice because
then your device doesn't
have to have a GPS
receiver, which
could be more expensive
than the rest of the device.
The GPS receiver needs to see
the satellites to hear them,
and it also consumes
a lot of power.
Of course, you can have GPS, and
you can send the coordinates.
But with Sigfox
Atlas Positioning,
you can get a rough
estimate of the location
no matter what kind
of device you have.
So imagine that
you are monitoring
the transport of some goods--
maybe some frozen items
that need to stay frozen--
from the manufacturing
all the way to the shop,
so you need to verify
the cold chain quality.
So if you'll just put a sensor
there in the container--
physical container
in this case--
and occasionally send
these sensor readings,
you can get a real time update
when, for example, something
starts to melt, or
temperature's going up.
And then, with this positioning
system, you can even see where.
Maybe it's on 101 going up to
San Francisco or something.
You get a rough estimate
of the location.
So let's see how we could
use the same system with that
Sigfox Atlas Positioning,
BigQuery GIS--
the new functionality
in BigQuery
for geographical queries--
and Google Maps.
So let's switch back, and
let's take a look at BigQuery.
There's something else I
didn't show you earlier.
So when I showed you earlier
that, now in BigQuery,
we have the data
coming from the device.
Very nice.
Yes.
They are here.
But if we scroll right,
there's more columns.
Here, we can see that actually
as part of the metadata coming
from Sigfox, when Sigfox
is forwarding the data
to the backend system,
it's also including
the computed location,
latitude and longitude,
based on the Sigfox
Atlas estimated location
of the device, based on
which base stations actually
heard the message.
So you start having coordinates
in your BigQuery database.
And what can you do with those?
Well, for example, this.
So BigQuery now supports GIS--
so geographical queries.
So we have a nice
visualizer where
you can start testing things.
So specify your project,
your GCP project, and then,
for example, you query BigQuery
with a standard SQL query,
but you put there a
specific value, GEO point.
So you're telling the system
that, hey, these two column
values here in my data
warehouse actually
contain geographical position
coordinates, latitude
and longitude.
So that's the first part in
the SELECT statement there.
WKT will then contain
the coordinates.
And then I'm also
asking, or querying
from BigQuery, the device ID,
the temperature, humidity,
and battery level
from the device data.
And then let's see what
happens when I click Run.
So now we are executing that
query live against BigQuery,
and currently we are looking
at the last 20 messages.
Let me increase
that to 30 messages.
Let's look at the
last 30 messages.
You can see that
I'm actually from--
I live in Singapore, so when
we go back in time more,
you can see that Singapore
starts coming up.
So basically, this is
now asset tracking.
We are tracking
my device earlier,
and if I put the query back
to last 20 rows in BigQuery,
everything should be near here.
What I actually did was
I drove around this bay,
and my device was transmitting
at regular intervals.
So we got some
transmissions there.
And if we zoom in
here to Google I/O,
you can see that all these
messages were transmitted
during I/O. So if I
click on one of these,
you can see that we
have Google Maps,
and we are overlaying, on
Google Maps, map pointers.
And the data in the pointer
is the actual device
data coming from BigQuery, so
we don't have any extra tools
here.
All of these are native
from GCP in Google tools,
so we have a nice,
easy Maps integration
with geographical
data in BigQuery here.
So that's very handy.
Quite often, it's good to know
where your IoT devices are,
and you can do things like
geofencing, for example.
Have an accent when your
device enters or exits
a certain radius--
a certain area.
So with that, I really hope
that you found this useful,
and I hope that you enjoyed it.
A couple of useful links here.
Please let me know
how you think.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]